je suis sûr que vous avez le même
constat que moi notre société a beaucoup
de défis si c'est des défis politique
confessionnel
économique financière sans parler des
problèmes environnementaux et
écologiques
maintenant nous avons le choix soit nous
nous recroquevillerons de notre carapace
et on attend que la tempête passe un peu
comme la neige cette nuit
où nous nous agitons comme des hamsters
en fait dans une cage et on essaie
d'appliquer des modèles dont on sait
déjà qu'ils sont plus applicables
on peut sombrer dans la morosité le
négativisme qui nous est projetée par
les médias
où nous réinventant de nouveaux modèles
un nouveau monde qui avec optimisme et
avec créativité
maintenant nous les adultes c'est un peu
compliqué parce que les schémas et les
modèles sont bien ancrés en nous et plus
peut-être moi que vous en faites qui est
plus jeunes ici on agrandit dont le
capitalisme la pleine croissance le
plein emploi c'est plus compliqué donc
notre regard se porte vers les enfants
les enfants comme je dis toujours qu'ils
sont de la matière première vierge
on peut encore les emmener vers cet
optimisme et cette envie d'entreprendre
et de transformer sauf que le système
d'éducation qui est en place aujourd'hui
tapis à son temps il a peu changé les
schémas qu'on applique sont encore assez
semblables qui lie à 50 cents ans
comment faire en fait pour emmener ses
enfants l'éducation nationale a et av
autrefois un grand objectif
cet objectif étant de scolariser tous
les enfants de france de les amener vers
un diplôme le brevet ou le baccalauréat
on l'aimait mettez en est mais en badge
selon l'année de naissance dans des
casses on applique des programmes les
programmes qui sont les mêmes pour tous
les enfants de france
les programmes avec des objectifs par
année
pour ces enfants dans cette caste et
pour tous les enfants de france
maintenant vous savez aussi
comme le nvidia et que vous connaissez
certainement mais aussi par rapport à
votre expérience personnelle en
université à l'école en entreprise
dans la famille que nous sommes tous
différents et heureusement
il y en a qui sont plus cartésiens
d'autres plus artistique et c'est ça qui
fait la richesse en fin de notre
collaboration pour un monde meilleur
la pédagogie montessori regard de
l'enfant dans son individualité
à travers la pédagogie montessori
l'enfant se construit soi même avant
l'âge de 6 ans c'est là où beaucoup de
pas chose en fait se passe la confiance
en soi l'estimé de soi
faire des choix
apprendre de l'erreur surmonter l'erreur
l'autonomie
le savoir être
et à travers ça l'enfant est accompagné
dans une case montessori par l'adulte un
adulte qui a une posture qui très
différentes d'un enseignant dans le
système classique
l'adulte et là ils observent l'enfant il
lui présente une activité avec du
matériel pédagogique
il va regarder où sont ses difficultés
ses forces ses faiblesses va l'aider à
surmonter ses faiblesses et accélérée là
où il est très fort
sans barrières
on va aller aussi loin que possible
et l'adulte bas se servir du matériel
pédagogique nous avons plus de 800
différents matériels en classe de
maternelle seulement
du matériel qui est partagé en
différents airs ou partie
commençons par la vie pratique la vie
pratique qui a un objectif très concret
s'est autonomisée l'enfant dans la vie
quotidienne
les enfants apprennent par exemple alice
et des boulons
à verser de l'eau dans des d'un verre à
l'autre sont renversés
avant ces dépenses à l'ange
premier objectif l'autonomie savoir se
débrouiller tout seul tout seul dans une
autre petite environnement deuxième
objectif pour chacune de ses activités
à prendre déjà à hanter en fait dans
l'apprentissage du langage et des
mathématiques
par exemple si je vous parle des devises
et des bouleaux on va déjà entraîné la
dextérité qui prépare à la pince de
crabe qui préparent à tenir un crayon et
on va apprendre le graphisme et
l'écriture
après on a le matériel sensorielle un
enfant avant l'âge de 6 ans à déployer
un 100% je dirais presque à 120 % ces
cinq sens on en profite pleinement
tous ces apprentissages l'odorat
l'ouïe le toucher
et pour ça en fait on les emmène là à
nouveau en fait vers le langage pour
apprendre à lire avec les sons l'analyse
des sons
on les emmène aussi vers les
mathématiques par rapport à nos
discernement des formes géométriques et
berne vers la numération
tout ce matériel est aussi complété
à des sciences
au tanit par exemple
et les arts la musique la peinture etc
ce matériel est scientifiquement prouvé
par les neurosciences grâce aux irm que
nous avons à disposition aujourd'hui je
ne dois pas certainement vous dire que
la pédagogie montessori date il ya 100
ans mais aujourd'hui être arrêté repos
donc vous allez me dire si cette
pédagogie forme un être humain prête à
partir transformer le monde savoir qu'il
est être autonome et 13 entrepreneurs en
plus c'est scientifiquement prouvé mais
pourquoi n'y en a pas plus en france
moi parce que c'est très cher
à ce que les écoles montessori sont des
écoles à 98 % hors contrat qu'est ce que
ça veut dire hors contrat hors contrat
ça veut dire aucune subvention publique
par exemple une école sous contrat
catholique que vous connaissez
certainement aller les enseignants sont
les salaires des enseignants sont pris
en charge par l'éducation nationale
les écoles hors contrat ne reçoivent
rien les enseignants les éducateurs sont
formés par un institut agréé par
l'association montessori internationale
pendant un an et nous devons les payer
comme les loyers comme toutes les
charges vaincre aujourd'hui dans une
école montessori classique
les frais de scolarité s'élèvent à peu
près à 600 à 800 euros par mois par
enfant
donc vous allez tout de suite comprendre
que ce n'est pas accessible à tout le
monde on estime à peu près
l'accessibilité en moins de 5% de la
population française il y en a qui
peuvent se saigner enfin tout ce qu'ils
veulent choisir ça
notre part hier d'accès à la pédagogie
montessori c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez
d'écoles saluons doivent y habiter en
ville dans une grande ville pour pouvoir
faire ce choix
vous savez quoi
moi j'ai commencé ce constat
et ça m'a vraiment
mais vraiment révolté et ensemble avec
mes deux associés
nous avons créé montessori 21
le premier réseau d'éco et montessori
solidaire participative
solidaires
parce que nous faisons partie de
l'économie sociale et solidaire mais
surtout parce que nous appliquons un
quotient familial
les enfants les parents payent des frais
de scolarité selon leurs revenus allant
de 90 à 850 euros par mois
et nous appliquons aussi des bourses
pour des parents qui auraient des
difficultés financières passagères
parce que nous souhaitons qu'il ya une
vraie continuité
de scolarisation et d'apprentissage des
enfants
participative il ya un vrai raison
économique vous avez certainement
compris aussi
mais comme je vous ai dit au départ les
enfants sont de la même matière première
vierge
les parents les parents font un choix
très audacieux
un choix contre un système karstique
mais ils sont pas très conforter nous on
a besoin de les prendre en charge leur
montrer les bénéfices de notre très
belles baies de goji
c'est pour ça qu'ils viennent en fait
nous aider à l'intérieur de l'école on
ouvre les pores on les forme en échange
avec eux on discute on les écoute leurs
peurs leurs angoisses qui sont présents
de plus en plus
et les écoles sont bilingues
ce que nous sommes
nous sommes d'avis que le bilinguisme
avant l'âge de 6 ans où l'enfant ne sait
pas qu'il apprend une langue qu'il
apprend tout court d'ailleurs est très
très important pour tous les enfants et
pas seulement les enfants issus de
familles pile culturel ou d'expatriés
alors nous avons ouvert notre première
école en 2015 dans le 92
et c'est à cette ouverture nous avons
été inondés
de deux demandes de personnes qui ont
dit mais comment vous avez fait c'est
tellement génial ça fait plaisir
évidemment
là nous avons vu une vraie opportunité
pro b c cette deuxième par hyères
d'apporter plus de pédagogie montessori
au niveau de la géographie nationale
nous avons créé notre réseau la tête du
réseau qui accompagne aujourd'hui des
personnes comme nous étions quand on a
démarré
dont la volonté de créer de l'impact
auprès des enfants l'éducation des
enfants
pour créer des écoles montessori 21
partout en france
nous les accompagnons il y a maintenant
quatre écoles depuis deux ans et demi à
la rentrée 2010 8 on aura neuf et dans
trois ans il y en aura 30
vous multipliez en fait
quant à peu près 100 enfants kara par
école là vous voyez en fait l'impact que
nous pouvons créer même pas que nous
créons pas seulement en fait auprès des
enfants
mais toute la communauté qui et se met à
l'oeuvre
les enfants les éducateurs
des parents
les directeurs les porteurs de projets
tous nous travaillons ensemble
pour transformer le monde parce que
c'est ça notre vrai notre vraie volonté
c'est pour ça aussi que nous nous
appelons montessori 21 21 pour le 21e
siècle pour les compétences du 21ème
siècle qui sont comme je vous ai dit en
fait on les compétences et aussi le
savoir
donc je vous dis si vous avez envie
aussi de transformer à travers à
l'éducation des enfants les enfants dès
le monde en fait à travers les enfants
vous pouvez devenir éducateur montessori
c'est passionnant vous pourrez brille
une école avec nous quelque part en
france parce qu'on a encore beaucoup de
place
mais surtout vous pouvez passer la
parole en fête à tous ceux que vous
connaissez à dire la pédagogie
montessori ciel vous intéresse elle est
accessible maintenant à tout le monde
merci
[Applaudissements]